- Give it up for my band y'all,
as I was saying, everybody.
That song was Walkaway Joe,
by Mrs.Trisha Yearwood and Don Henley.
I love Trisha Yearwood y'all, seriously
one of my favorite singers on the planet.
Let's meet Matthew who
requested that song.
So where are you at Matthew?
- Austin, Texas
- It's Matthew McConaughey!
- How you doing Kelly?
- How are you doing?
- Relatively pretty well,
we're trying to get over
this freeze down here,
you know, it kind of knocked
some of us back a hair
but overall we're doing pretty good.
- Yeah. Oh my God.
That's good to hear, that's good to hear.
Why did you request Walkway Joe?
- Well, Walkaway Joe, and it
was, think it was early 1992,
I'm going to college here
at the University of Texas.
This is before Dazed and Confused,
and I was trying to get odd jobs
in front of the camera when I could.
And I got cast in that
music video to play Joe.
Things are going well then where
we ended up at the last
stop, she wakes up,
and "Joe", myself, is nowhere to be seen.
Therefore, AKA the title, Walkaway Joe.
- I love that though, don't you remember?
I love that about country
music videos, especially
in like the nineties, there
would be such a story,
like a plot, they'd have actors,
really big actors, and
I think that's amazing.
I didn't know that was your first thing.
I didn't know that was
before Dazed and Confused.
It's amazing.
- That, and Unsolved Mysteries.
Yeah. Walkaway Joe was my first
time in front of the camera.
And I still don't believe
I've met Trisha in person.
- Did you just say that
and unsolved mysteries?
- [Matthew] Yes.
I love you so much! That's amazing.
Not that I'm complaining, because
I love you, everyone does,
but what are you doing
here in our audience?
- I am here in your audience today
because as you know, as
I mentioned a minute ago,
our state, Texas, was hit
by the worst freeze it's had
in over 70 years and
Texans were without power.
There's still a lot of
them without clean water.
They have major water damage
some are without food.
Some can't move back into their homes.
Kids can't go back to the schools.
And myself and Camila are hosting
and throwing a We Are
Texas virtual concert.
That's going to be on my YouTube channel
on March 21st at 7:00
PM, central Texas time.
As my brother calls it, "real time",
and we got a hell of a
show we're gonna put out.
We've got a lot of great performers.
I'm calling it a
restoration Texas concert.
It's going to be a revival.
It's not going to be a sob show.
It's going to be a jam
session of generosity.
- I love that.
I love, I actually, I was
very excited that you asked me
to be a part of it because one,
it's a really cool thing to
be able to have a spotlight
like you have in the industry.
And then you get to use it for good.
When it really counts and matters.
And also then I love that you made it more
of an uplifting thing of
just jamming out instead
of just such a somber
thing, because it's already
been kind of a melancholy moment,
the past year and a half.
And so I think it was really important.
So what organizations are
you raising money for?
- A hundred percent of the donations,
meaning 100 cents on every dollar donated.
Is going to go through our
Just Keep Living Foundation:
Texas Relief Fund.
And it's going to go to
organizations all over Texas,
in the urban areas and in
the rural parts of Texas.
places like St.Bernard Project,
Team Rubicon on the
ground, Save the Children,
Austin Disaster Relief, Meals
on Wheels to name a few.
These are organizations that
are helping out real needs
that are fixable with the right donations
right now in Texas.
- Absolutely are fixable.
I love that.
And honestly, I was
excited to watch it myself
and be able to be a part of it because
the guest list of people
coming it's so random.
- [Matthew] Well, that was
one of the cool things.
I mean, the lineup is
pure Texas and it's deep.
You know, like I said,
you've got yourself.
You've got Don Henley.
You got Gary Clark Jr, George
Strait, Kacey Musgraves,
you, Khalid, Kirk Franklin, Leon Bridges,
Lucas Nelson, Lyle
Lovett, Miranda Lambert,
Parker McCollum, Post Malone,
Randy Rogers, Willie Nelson.
I mean, that's all Texas talent,
and we couldn't even fit
in all the Texas talent.
So it's going to be a
hell of a fun night and
all those musicians cover quite
a few genres of good music.
- Yeah, that's what I'm
saying it's an amazing thing
because that's another
thing I love about Texas,
and everybody will come
together and it will get fixed.
And you said this is a fixable situation,
all these situations.
And I love that about Texans.
We are so random, like the
set list of people there,
it's such a random variety of people,
but I think that's
what's cool about Texas,
is it doesn't matter where you come from,
everybody's invited to the party
and everybody's welcome to join in,
and everybody wants to help everybody,
that's why I love
growing up in that state.
But what else can people do
help each other down there?
- Well, I wanted to bring
up another cool thing
and you know this as a Texan,
and this is a really
cool thing about Texas.
Texans, we like to help ourselves.
And what we're going to
be doing with this relief,
with this benefit is donations
are going to be helping
out people that want to help themselves
and are trying to help
themselves, but are unable to.
And boy, that's a great way.
To anyone out there wants to
give know that you're giving it
to people who have already
pulled their bootstraps up.
And they're saying, I'm
trying to help myself.
I'm just having trouble doing so.
- Yeah. Absolutely, absolutely.
What else can people
do to help down there?
Like other than obviously be
a part of the virtual benefit
and be a part and donate money?
What else do you think people should
- [Matthew] Look, time.
You know, people in Texas right now
let's remind everyone
out there right now is
no better time than to go
knock on your neighbor's door
or see if someone else is having trouble
around in your neighborhood,
in your community.
There's plenty of help to go around.
So if you can give your time,
if you can give a little effort,
even going by to see
somebody, we've got stories
of people that had their door knocked on,
that people just hadn't talked to anybody,
they've been stuck in their
home with water damage
and not even gone out and
to see a neighbor come by
and just check on them,
meant something to them.
So keep your ears open and eyes open
around your own neighborhoods,
people need it all over the state.
And if there's a way you can also
donate your time in the long run,
we're talking to people like
Team Rubicon, more people.
If you don't want to
donate a dollar or five,
or however much, you can donate
your time to go help people
on the ground in Texas here too.
- [Kelly] That's so great.
What's an example of
something you've seen,
one Texan doing for
another through all this?
I know there's gotta be plenty.
- Yeah. Yeah. And this parlays
off of what I was just saying
about how these Texans are people
who want to help
themselves, but need help.
And these donations are
going to help those people
that want to help themselves.
There's for instance, there's this lady
in Houston and she's an older lady,
but very young in spirit and pure Texan.
She gets up the morning after the freeze
and she heads out into a neighborhood
and she starts helping out
her neighbors who had damage.
And I mean, she's in the middle of it
getting dirty, helping out.
She gets up the next
day, she does it again.
We hear about this story.
We went down to go cover her,
neighbors helping neighbors.
Wow, isn't this a great story.
Somebody who's helping out a neighbor.
Only to find out that that night,
when we followed her home to her apartment
her apartment had busted water lines,
flooding, collapsed ceilings.
And she was like, Oh, I
wasn't even bringing that up.
I was going to help somebody else out
that I think maybe
needed more help than me.
And she needed help, and she
wouldn't even ask for help.
- Oh that's so Texan.
- So I helped people like that as well.
- That's amazing that she had
this, God, what a great heart.
Wow.
- Right?
For more information
on how you can help go
to our Instagram story or
check out Matthew's Instagram
and to watch the We Are Texas
Virtual Benefit Concert go
to Matthew's YouTube page on March 21st.
Thank you so much for being
here, Matthew, we love you.
Thank you so much.
- Thank you, Kelly.
Thank you for your performance
too, with the show.
We're going to do a lot of
good for a lot of good people.
- [Kelly] Oh man. I hope so, I hope so.